good I guess alright let's go for it
let's go for everybody welcome back
Duffy intro oh you tape hey welcome back
to x-play drunk minecraft with my scarib
uh special guests here this guy no no
real talk real talk like Bob you are the
star of the show you do Donna you do
know that right
like I'm not I'm literally all I ever do
is call you guys [ __ ]
yeah but no you're so funny when you do
like say it [ __ ]
I'm gonna have a laugh track the Darwin
Greg left that was way too much Gilligan
ha ha ha like huge applause after the
last wait do you know what make me the
happiest person in the world and I would
probably like use as a cell phone
ringtone what if you by yourself made a
markiplier laugh track just overlaid a
bunch of you laughing with like
ridiculous laughs and yeah you could and
then I was up mmm
ya know do different do different
reactions to I would ha ha I can make a
whole soundboard this just me likes just
a million of me Oh God okay anyway what
we're gonna do is we're not gonna do the
drinking contest we're just gonna take a
three manly three second sip of all of
our drinks okay you guys ready cheers
guys here we go ah good start good start
mmm oh god he's gone again but what oh
boy
hey that's a lot of bourbon well I
didn't measure my shots out this time I
just poured that's a lot of bourbon you
see that mom okay anyway so this is um
super super minecraft browser so super
cool super spy raps ready to 1 no
breaking or placing about ever number
two no killing you till the games begin
number three do not leave the map area
number four if you can't get back to the
map area kill yourself number five of
your spectating stay out of the way of
arrows number six do not drop items from
your inventory where your characters
armor at all times
no pressing the sync key you must flesh
with spawn as fast as possible don't be
a dick don't blame Wade you see this
obey mark
Wade you see this rule here yeah we got
more rules over here no come here this
is very important Wade come here you see
this out
god damn it Wade I'm gonna excuse that
because you didn't read the rule yet oh
we're at it no don't kill ha you should
rule time damn okay Peggy you learned it
I was trying to read the sign Wade
you're going to do anything to read
signs all right hang on the game hasn't
even started yet we got to go pick a
color well I guess I'm player one oh my
god well what happened whoa whoa what I
don't see any characters all I see are
blanks what the hell am I am the
shittiest character ever here all I have
is potions you're a creeper oh my god
you're a creeper what am i I'm a wither
hell yeah I'm a friggin wither helmet
can I change oh no I can't I don't have
a helmet Horace why not oh my god this
is so cool
nether fortress village mushroom island
there's so many maps all I have in my
inventory is potions you don't have
nothing else to put on um oh mighty
creeper in the sky whoa I can jump like
a lot all right I'm just gonna pick
random map okay guys ready all I have is
an infinite supply of splash potion of
harming alright seem pretty good to me
ready here we go I've got one arrow boom
oh boy
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa oh honey
goddamn [ __ ] oh I didn't fight it was
you wait I know it's you none of us got
killed by anybody we all fell out of the
world oh and then I started are you
kidding me and I have none of my
inventory cuz you guys are
stupid yeah haha goddamn [ __ ] [ __ ]
you get to pick a different character
this time at least - hey I don't have a
bow anymore
what the crap is this have you picked a
cactus man oh god
cactus garb I'm gonna pick a different
uh we're gonna do stronghold okay I hope
this works
oh god don't move don't move don't move
don't move oh yeah
why happening when we get a magical sky
God can you uh port us - oh my god what
happened are you guys Bob wait I'm out
of the game I don't know what's going on
well I'm upstairs wait
Bob wait no I go oh god nah
come on oh you know what [ __ ] it
we're building a penis cannon like I
wanted to do no gift zombie blow up
everything and send us to a flat world
blow up everything I'm inside your
inside where the thing you want to blow
up will blow it up then oh god no we're
gonna die oh wait what oh I'm not dying
wanna die yes yay god damn jerk
cactus again oh no oh you're so dumb did
you break the block oh my God we're
fighting
oh is that uh-uh-uh-uh-uh
I died I guess I'm gonna count that as a
victory where the hell am i I picked up
a hammer all right what the hell is this
argh I've got a hammer I don't know
where I am I see control off I know I'm
like in the back programming world oh my
god wait no I see something down there I
guess whoa wait do you see this [ __ ] no
don't kill him out
you deserve that Wade you dick that's
not less complicated wait Bob fall out
of the world for a second I don't wanna
I'm winning no seriously we're not there
fall out of the world you'll parently be
ported to this weirdo place ooh I'd to
fall out on a specific side Oh anywhere
dude wait look at look down below
there's something down there yeah looks
like a bow when you're next to it what
well looks like a bow it's like a bow
and arrow no down whoa what the heck I
know I'm doesn't look like a bow this
time yeah I'm gonna go down there ah I
flew I made it there's webbing down here
Bob come on up make it to the webbing oh
I didn't make it to the leg it to the
wedding
where's the webbing it's in the middle
of it I can't even see it from where is
it it's down oh okay
yeah wait made it yeah what uncle I'll
be gawked urgent buhdeuce like that like
that you [ __ ]
you like that there was a rollercoaster
here no and I don't know why I can drink
to that
I just don't wake it launched into the
distance like to try and give the most
pathetic scream would you quit here with
that
rich is I don't even know what's
happening but I like it a goddammit oh
I'm still alive
I can't move I've lost my oh I'm just
pushing the wrong buttons oh oh oh god
I'm dead oh wait you [ __ ] suck
uh-huh oh man I didn't even I don't even
know anymore I don't even know anymore
hey zombie can we uh um this happen no
I'm trapped Oh guys come look at where
I'm trapped hang on where are you oh
it's dark what what what I missed
what's happening I don't know
zombie I'm trapped in a black hole Oh B
oh I'm gonna flip the switch
zombie myself with a potion what
happened
I threw a potion of harming yeah I have
no inventory I didn't used to be like
giant humps in the middle here no no a
maybe I don't know where it goes our
lovely lady lumps uh I don't have any
lovely lady lumps on iphone hole oh no
I'm stuck oh god oh god are you sucking
the blackness of the whole bobbum what's
you hey my god I can't see how'd you
guys get to a black hole jump in the
center of one of those thingies
haha are Bob gonna work week early can't
move or see anything not just the whole
episode like I don't have any more
potions
god damn it Bobby where are you
we were abandoned by our maker
dolly jumpin Tommy talk zombie tell all
my fans your beautiful voice
what let all my fans know zombies all
broken is beyond voice in zombie dub a
dub a break is all broken everything is
broken you can't even port us oh wait
I'm out I'm out I'm out I'm out I'm Bob
I'm out I don't believe you did you get
any ender pearls while you were in there
the world is family you know I just like
my faith in humanity
I don't disbelieve you zombie boy I mean
come on man
oh my gosh everything is in heaven it
fix it oh god I don't know where I'm
going oh god damn it I felt by I'll
stuck in the abyss of suckiness all
commands are bonked yeah all all the
commands are not working is the problem
where am I gonna go how'd you get out I
sure do I had to ender pearls when I
went in there what stuck with him on ah
[ __ ] can you like throw some in the hole
that I'm in I don't know let me try I
don't know which which hole are you in
again I don't remember uh it's the one
life that you spawn on when you die I'm
trying to throw things in each hole
hopefully you'll get some turn my balls
in your hole
yes that's not good oh wait no sorry you
weren't going for that joke no oh I'm
old god I'm so sorry
alright catch one of the balls I'm
throwing I don't oh I'm out of what here
men [ __ ] I know about drunk minecraft
who's Lester progressively get backward
bum just drink now I'm drinking yeah
you're right cheers everyone have a good
one oh god this game is breaking us oh
my god this is oh oh it's beautiful oh
oh it's like we came out of the oceans
like what good are you oh why am i here
alone Oh God oh no I walked around and
everything got broken oh yeah we ended
up on this Oh on this island we ought to
survive my outfit doesn't match oh yeah
you're like a spider head in a cactus
body oh but we made it to this I don't
kill me why where did you get it oh no
it's okay No
Oh course is not the game we got the
game has changed I can jump like a
magician I'm camouflaged can you guys
see me uh-oh
where did Bob go I don't know let's see
are these cactus wait why is that gonna
catch move on and hold sword Oh oh crap
whoa what uh wait a minute
oh wait your jump alight oh wait weird
where did Bob go where did Bob go
there's a square structure over here
Lily is there now whoa wait no it's just
the end of oh my god what Justin was it
on I'm in everything Oh God oh no
there's like something ha ha
fall in the lava it'll save you God the
woman what lava breaks falls alright Bob
your sword
maybe organ oh oh I got it okay so I'm
not gonna fall see if lava breaks my
fall don't do it no no no oh [ __ ]
oh my gosh it does I landed on a cliff
halfway down and I'm currently exploring
a cave the cliff
hahaha die
I don't have the falling protection
boots hang on I want to go back to that
ears what is what are all these cliffs
hi we don't need this we don't in terms
of stuff I don't have any has land don't
happen in that bomb oh this oh my gosh I
got out of the lava I think I might
survive I think I might survive
hey I did too hey no hey look at all
this [ __ ] I get yeah ohh oh my god now
I'm back up here hi Bob oh crap there's
powerful in this holy I'll jump in
ah there's cinder pearls what did we do
I don't you know this is like an episode
of Family Guy oh that's gonna happen on
this episode
what did we do what did we do oh my god
I need to buy two cute zombie can you
port them to me cuz I'm happy I'm at the
other side of that thing that we were
looking at I climbed up Marco to ICU
yeah I'm gonna eat it up I'm a-comin
lorry coming Wade there you are okay oh
it's just like it's like mine kinda I
know it's like normal minecraft but
there's this huge valley of NORTHCOM
bread and a saddle oh boy we're gonna
have a fun time uh yeah bark um your
life with the saddle on you
wait oh yeah please oh yeah oh oh
mark are you guys oh god
I'm not even there what are you doing Oh
Baba no I'm not no one's there
don't answer Bob I can have fun on my
own no way yeah
where'd you go Bob Wow what happened I'm
currently stuck in a stupid spider web
douche bag oh crap I'm stuck in there
with you Bob guys something just
exploded
that concerns me for the fate of this
world yeah break the mold hey I'm coming
whoa
I gonna climb up over Carter oh sorry to
break this foul beast there's a watch
our redstone and Cole and Wow
and diamonds what that doesn't do anyth
any good because we're just here not
there well look I could jump we don't
give a [ __ ] about what you can do Wade
this was probably what it's like to be
in the NBA
oh because you'll never realize your
dreams of being a professional
basketball player that's probably true
yeah it's true Wade we hate to break it
to you but even if you are basically
good at math oh hey those horses hey I
have a saddle hang on come here horse
I'm here
you need to tame it I'm taming it it
doesn't like oh wait okay back there
they don't Bob get back there hey me
ously you're behind it again it's just
like it's ready for the sky oh wait
here's that's not cheating
parents to the horse chickens are ready
from the sky hey Horace Cruiser your bad
chickens I can handle just even want
them yeah hey ba or no nabob zombie
creepers from the sky papers from one
guy and zombies wait what are you wait I
looked up you you can't say that Wade
but you can't say that I get worried
look at you children why can you jump
cuz I'm a spider-man Oh creepers from
this guy Bob Bob
ba-ba-ba-ba oh no oh no creepers ah oh
god what is reefer this Misco zombie
blow everything up everything whoa
aren't almost for like a ticket I don't
think so but Jame just blow everything
up it's time to end this travesty this
this this is gonna bring more guys is
this episode has gone awry I salute you
in the end of the world gentlemen oh
there's doom chicken
what's your chicken - chicken what are
you doing here
Oh aha
all right here's a bug in a stupid
things there's - you guys I'm a drinkin
we're all ah ring around the TNT oh oh
we are survivors mark of the apocalypse
it's still apocalypse thing so hug me as
we die okay wait I love you wait wait I
love your samples all right no I'm gonna
cut it off there it'll be the end of it
no wait no there will be one more I
didn't cut it they're gonna censor it
I'm gonna censored again is that what
you said last time
no no one's gonna know what I said is
besides Wade I I still don't actually
know what you said in that episode cuz I
know how hurt it if I said right now
will you censor it again yes I will say
it Wade say way
ha ha ha me god what else I happen ha ha
your guess is as good as mine
so that world that world with all those
commandblocks were like screwing with
the server I lost control of like every
command that I could possibly do I was
just getting errors constantly I was
being teleported around the map like
infinitely while you guys were like I
couldn't move it was doing it without my
permission I was just like I wish we had
absolving over I was like in a vortex of
crap yeah